على طرقات لبنان انتشرت اعلانات تقدم
حلولا لمشكله جواز السفر فالحصول على
تاشيره لصاحب جواز لبناني يحتل المرتبه
السادسه والتسعين بحسب مؤشر جيد لترتيب
الجوازات ليس بالامر السهل
وللمحافظه على استمراريه شركتها وتسهيل
اعمال عشرات الفروع المنتشره في الخارج لم
تجد داليا وسيله سوى شراء جواز سفر احد
الجزر الكاريبيه وانا الم كانت انه بدنا
نبقى بهالبلد بدنا نخلي مصنعنا بدنا نخلي
عيالنا بس بدنا نقدر نصدر الصناعه
اللبنانيه او المنتوج لبرا فمن هون طلعت
الفكره انه لا خليه يكون عنا اكسس
واكسبوجر للماركت نقدر نفتح تشانلز لبرا
لنخلي عيالنا بلبنان بهالمصنع انتقل لزياد
من العمل في سوق العقارات الى تشجيع
الاستثمار في جوازات السفر الحصول على
جواز جديد مضمون هنا شرط ان صاحب الطلب
متورطا امنيا او سبق وتم رفض منحه عددا
كبيرا من التاشيره
التابعين لكم
تحت امريكا
مقابل مصاري بيندرس الفايل تبعه وبينقبل
وبياخد الجنسيه هذا اول بارت هذه هي
الجنسيه وفي بروجرامات باوروبا
عندك باليونان عندك باسبانيا
في منهم توصل للجنسيه وفي اغلبيتهم الفكره
من هدول بروجرامات
هنيك ما تغيري شي بحياتك ويكون عندك
مئه لبنانيين وجدوا في هذه الخدمه ملذا
فيما دولتهم باتت عاجزه حتى عن تجديد
جوازات سفرهم اصبحت هذه الجوازات بوابه
عبور اللبنانيين المقتدرين نحو العالم اما
من لا يملك المبالغ اللازمه فيبقى السيره
جواز سفر لبناني يتبول لائحه اسوا جوازات
العالم غنوه يتيم العربيه بيروت لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات